veamos si podemos sumar tres décimos con
7 centésimos y antes de que lo hagamos
juntos te invito a que lo intentes por
tu cuenta te voy a dar una ayuda así
como esta es difícil de sumar pues aquí
tenemos fracciones que tienen
denominadores distintos el denominador
de tres décimos es diferente al de 7
centésimos pero lo que te sugiero es que
transformers 3 decimos a centésimos para
que lo puedas sumar con estos 7
centésimos
supongo que ya lo probaste vamos a hacer
esta suma vamos a transformar primero
tres décimos pero antes vamos a
visualizar esta transformación lo que he
hecho aquí esto lo puedes considerar
como un entero este también es un entero
este entero está dividido en décimos uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez decimos vamos a marcar aquí
tres decimos aquí tenemos uno
y tres decimos aquí tenemos tres decimos
ahora qué pasa si tomamos todos y cada
uno de estos diez décimos y lo dividimos
en diez partes iguales es decir vamos a
tomar cada uno de estos décimos y los
vamos a dividir en diez partes iguales
si tenemos originalmente diez partes
iguales y a la vez cada una de esas
partes las hemos dividido en diez partes
iguales entonces hemos dividido el
entero en centésimas pongámoslo así
teníamos originalmente diez décimas que
dividimos a la vez en diez partes
iguales por lo cual tenemos 100
centésimas y entonces tres décimas a
cuántas centésimas equivale bien cada
uno de estos décimos se transformó en 10
centésimos vamos a dibujarlos aquí
tenemos
decimos aquí hay otros 10 centésimos
déjame dibujarlo bien para que quede
bien marcado y aquí tenemos otros 10
centésimos entonces cuántos tenemos
tenemos 3
tres décimos quedan originalmente tres
por
cada uno tiene diez partes iguales tres
por diez 30 centésimos 10 por 10 es
igual a 100 así es como vamos a
transformar nuestro denominador en vez
de tenerlo en décimas lo vamos a tener
ahora en centésimas el numerador ahora
tenemos tres décimas lo queremos pasar a
centésimas aquí vemos que son 3 por 10
sería entonces multiplicar esto 3 por 10
que son cada una estas centésimas 3 por
10 y también abajo multiplicamos por 10
de esa manera no alteramos la expresión
aún sigue representando tres décimos de
un entero nada más que ahora está en
centésimas así es que cuando hacemos
esto que obtenemos vamos a escribirlo
aquí abajo tenemos 30 sobre 100 10
décimos es equivalente a 100 centésimos
ya eso tenemos que sumarle 7 sobre 100
hemos establecido que tres décimos
equivale a 30 centésimos ya eso hay que
sumarle 7 centésimos vamos a tener ahora
37 centésimos
esto es igual a 30
+ 7 tenemos el mismo denominador 137
sobre 100 y esto es igual a 37 sobre 100
37 centésimas
así es que esos 7 centésimos que hemos
agregado
vamos a
iluminar lo en nuestro esquema voy a
agarrar otro color para que se note
estos 7 centésimos van a ser 12 deja de
marcar lo más claramente 45 deja ver
hasta dónde llegaría aquí tenemos 1 2 3
hasta que llegaría aquí tendríamos esos
extra 7 centésimos que estamos sumando
estos son 7 vamos a ponerlo aquí arriba
mejor
estos son 7 centésimos y en total
tenemos 30 más 737 centésimos